I recently traveled to Italy with my
associate producer Jordan shlonsky a
self-described
expert on all things Italian especially
their food and our trip included a
required stop at Jordans favorite
Italian restaurant so I decided to
return the favor
Jordan you showed me your Italy now I
show you my Italy when Jordan oh I
wasn't sold on Olive Garden mm-hm but
once I saw an ad where they brought an
old man from Italy and they took him to
all of garden and he took a taste of
this food and he became emotional
[Music]
possible that he is an actor now you
look at commercial and that guy is
overwhelmed with emotion right because
he's having the best Italian food he's
had since his mama made him to linguine
when he was a Bambino please tell this
gentleman hello we are looking very much
forward to our meal today
buona sera CMO multiple dj2 yesterday
quad Wow beautiful oh you speak English
I do I do it speak English where are you
from well I'm from Texas
you've margaritas we do have an Italian
margarita yes maybe even margarita by
definition a Mexican drink excuse me
it's an Italian margarita and it's quite
clear to me this is amazing that the
Mexicans stole the margarita from Italy
we would like to have two of your
Italian margaritas please I don't want
an Italian marker excuse me men do way
am I allowed to speak and interact I'm
here to teach you I am the master you're
a student
I am Yoda right and you won't die Walker
you're not really Luke Skywalker you're
sort of like a sickly Chewbacca oh my
god we didn't even order this no it
comes included with every meal for as
long as you're here we can keep on
bringing the breadsticks to you really
yeah it's incredible my left man nipple
we're gonna need two more plates of
these okay absolute you like to try it
buy it no hey have a bite please that
looks like a ha I think we're gonna
start by enjoying these Italian
margaritas I'm not a big fan of hard
alcohol you should have said that before
you order an Italian margarita if you
check the tape you'll see that you
ordered an Italian margarita we would
like to have two of your Italian
margaritas please
I plan themed good length order and in
Fountain Inn margarita we will have the
steak gorgonzola
Alfredo's Jordan how do you like your
steak prepared medium rare okay so we'll
have that well-done please I wanted to
point out there's a grammatical error on
the menu you have written here lasagne
classic Oh in fact by that reckoning
would be lasagna classic ah more
commonly known as lasagna classic a also
with your fettuccine alfredo I noticed
that it's includes fresh cream and
garlic of course the original recipe
from Rome is just butter and
parmigiano-reggiano my question to you
is is the Parmesan cheese listed here an
American
Parmesan cheese or in fact and authentic
parmigiano-reggiano from the region of
emilia romagna excuse me is it James
yes if you'd like to stab him be my
guest
I feel that there is a an excess of
heavy cream used in Italian American
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations congratulations
nice to see you oh this thing of all the
places we visit in Italy what meal does
this most remind you of this doesn't
remind me it is Rome Cardona John Bonham
to see blubbered only in moraine who's
speaking gumbo grab the damn book Toro
so we can put cheese on any of the
dishes cheese it up okay just let me
know when no I do not need any cheese on
it not mine either my favorite italian
phrase cheese it up do you mind if I
keep this
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]